a law that you will not be told
As a member of the jury, you know what you can do: judge guilty, or not guilty. But there are other options.
That is no matter what the judge or lawyer will not tell you - most of the time they are not allowed to do so, at the same time
You may not know "not sure".
This video will tell you the third option, but note: it’s possible to just "watch"
So that you can never serve in the jury - so this is the last chance you pressed the pause button
Before you know...
Jury veto: When the defendant is 100% reasonably found guilty, "but"
The jurors "at the same time" think that he should not be punished. The jury can ignore the law and release him without guilt
But before you next serve as a jury and call the judge a "veto!" you should know first.
Inappropriate circumstances, even just talking about the jury veto may also cause you to be arrested.
However, if this film is just a "presence" that affirms the jury veto, and
"There is absolutely no intention to advocate" is completely ok.
Additional note: (CGP Grey is not a lawyer, this is not a legal advice but for entertainment purposes only)
Seriously, everyone, don’t do anything online to tell you in the court.
Not kidding. )
So why can't you do this? Because the veto does not stand in the "legal" of the legal text, but as
The logical result of the other two regulations exists:
First: jurors cannot be punished for making "wrong" judgments - whether or not there are clear witnesses,
DNA, or video shows that the defendant is guilty. The focus of the jury is to be a final arbitrator.
as well as
Second: If the defendant is found not guilty, then he will no longer be tried
The same crime.
So there are only two options that can be stipulated: guilty or not guilty, just because the jury’s waiver is used
When the jurors’ arguments are not in line with the considerations (meaning, for example, the jury’s considerations seem to be guilty of the law but they do not consider the accused to be punished) – plus they cannot be punished
At the same time, the final acquittal they made could not be changed.
These regulations are necessary for the jury to be in a fair system, but the logical result is that .....
Controversial--the argument that lawyers and judges abstain from jury is like physicists arguing
Like quantum mechanics. Both are difficult to observe while the two are generally explaining
There are great differences in philosophical significance.
Then such veto power is the exercise of people’s will, or an anarchist act, or just
What is the way citizens judge the law?
An example of a veto power is the case of the fugitive slave law: that is, when the jury in the north
The veto is judged and the black slave is acquitted.
I have no opinion on this.
But the comparison is an example of deliberate disregard of the law. The southern jury refused to convict those white people who used lynchings against black people.
This is not very human.
But both are the same as jury's disregard of the law.
In fact, the jury has "two" choices when they say that the words do not match the judgment.
The jury veto is usually used in cases where the final judgment is not guilty, but the jury can also convict the defendant without evidence.
Just as they can release the accused without sin
This is also a type of jury veto, in which case they are protected by the first law, however
The second rule does not apply, and the judges have the ability to dismiss their guilty rulings.
The judge considered the jury .... is a problem. Of course, the guilty verdict is able to continue to appeal.
This makes the guilty ruling of the jury veto is weaker than the acquittal.
Do not be sad.
Given that there is a possibility that the jurors will veto the law as mentioned above, we can not see it unexpectedly.
Lawyers who exist under the rule of law society when we are doing juror candidates for screening
Ask questions about the veto, and usually in a more roundabout way:
Do you think that you will be able to make a judgment that is not in accordance with the provisions of the law?
After you know what the jury veto is, you might think that "will" is a better choice.
But then you will not get the jury qualification, but if you answer "no" in order to be a juror and make a judgment that ignores the law.
Then you commit a false oath (a more academic argument is a violation of federal law).
This approach can be said to be the best strategy for the jury to shut up.
But this has another problem for those who have an intention to veto the law: Tell the other 11 jurors
The veto will make your situation risky, which will make the veto unable to play its role as a correction of the unfair bill.
And become a national issue
(Not to mention that 95% of US criminal cases are not convicted in the final trial.
Instead, it ends with a confession negotiation, and this is another story.
The only question now is that the jurors should be "informed" of the jury's veto power?
Judging from the position of the general court, their decision would be: "I don't think about it"
This seems selfish and right - but the existence of the court is to follow the law - but it is indeed a proof
Telling the jury that a veto will change their decision at the final judgment will result in less evidence of court evidence than their decision.
This is not surprising: this is "the so-called jury veto." Simulated trial
It also shows that it is easier for a more sympathetic defendant to obtain a acquittal before the jury who knows the jury’s veto power.
A defendant who is not sympathized will easily get a guilty verdict
Compared to the results of trials that do not know the jury’s waiver
It sounds terrible, and we know that if the jurors
It’s very unfair to just follow the legal provisions blindly.
In the end, is such a system capable of exercising justice, or anarchism, or helping citizens to legislate?
The decision is in your hands -- but as long as the court system is fair, these regulations are needed.
So the jury veto will always be with us.